and finally new rule if Trump supporters
don't want us to call them stupid they
have to stop coming up with things like
queue yeah it was just a few months ago
in this space that I was talking about
how Republicans are now the conspiracy
party that there is literally nothing so
ridiculous they won't swallow
birth-certificate chemtrails Jade helm
lizard people and now we have Q what is
Q well Q is a person but we don't know
who it is we just know it's someone with
super high Q level security clearance so
he knows all the [ __ ] that goes on in
the deep state namely that our
government is riddled with a rogue
criminal element that is interested in
evil in general but their specialty is
pedophilia and why not almost half of
Trump voters already believed that
Hillary Clinton ran a child sex ring out
of a pizza parlor but it turns out that
was just the tip of the iceberg and
frankly it would be easier to find a
powerful person who isn't a pedophile
George Soros is one and so with the
Rothschilds JP Morgan John McCain the
Illuminati Tom Hanks Steven Spielberg
and every president since Reagan but not
Trump
oh no in the queue world he's the
superhero whose whole life has been a
cover so he could be in place to strike
back against the pedophile ring and then
it starts to get weird
Republicans please help me help me help
you help me help you because like it or
not we are family and you are like a
brother to me a sick alcoholic brother
who's lost his [ __ ] line
Trump rallies these days are full of
these queue people holding up signs and
defending their theory with ironclad
logic maybe it's not true because
there's no evidence of it it's a stuff
being talked about on the Internet right
there hasn't been any non evidence yet
you heard the lady there's no
non-evidence alpha [ __ ] sake I like
you people better when you were just
religious nuts I mean it can we have the
old religion back church is full of
horrible ridiculous ideas but it's
better than reddit I mean really the man
they think is combating pedophilia is
this guy I've said that if Ivanka
weren't my daughter perhaps I'd be
dating her she's six feet tall she's got
the best body well I was going to say
sex but I can't relate that but weights
weights weights remember remember what
the Dear Leader keeps telling us what
you're seeing and what you're reading is
not what's happening not what's
happening
[Applause]
that's right Donald Trump was just
posing as a disgusting pervert for the
last half century to gain credibility so
we go after the real perverts now the
most important thing to always remember
is that everything is the opposite of
what it appears every time Trump appears
to be a dump bumbling idiot that's
evidence of the exact opposite the exact
opposite the exact opposite
[Applause]
right the FBI are the traitors the real
Patriots are in Russia Trump is clean
Muller is dirty the only thing that
would make more sense would be finding
out that a Trump loathing conservative
bidder like me is Q which is why it is
true
you don't believe me just ask yourself
is there any not
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I
[Applause]
huh it feels so good to finally be
myself a computer whiz in a hoodie my
entire life has been a sham that gave me
the perfect cover to be your source for
what's really happening in America
the drugs the atheism the stuff at the
Playboy Mansion I did that to throw
everybody off the set I'm actually a
Presbyterian who goes to church every
Sunday with my wife and our homeschooled
twins Margaret and Thatcher
the pot I smoke is oregano and the jokes
in my monologue are actually coded
messages except for the ones about Chris
Christie being fat those I just like to
tell so now that you real Americans know
the truth i q-- need your help
to make America great again keep posting
your memes keep believing everything
Trump tells you and above all on Tuesday
November 6th stay at home do not leave
your house on November 6 for any reason
even - bye babe juice if you have a
basement go there or better get in the
trunk of your car close it and don't
leave for whatever reason just stay in
the trunk of your car until you hear
from me stay in the trunk
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]